bonsoir à tous merci de votre attention
qui est l'auteur du meurtre des petits
cyril et alexandra montigny les metz il
ya presque 16 ans patrick dils a déjà
été condamné à deux reprises mais pour
ce troisième procès jamais le doute n'a
été aussi grand et hier deux gendarmes
auteurs d'une contre-enquête indiqué que
le double meurtre
portrait la porte elle a quasi signature
du tueur en série francis heaulme
francis heaulme présents sur les lieux
du crime qui était interrogé aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas moi at il réaffirmé sur
place valérie ermite frédéric bonne
jamais le public n'aura été aussi
nombreux l'audience ne commence que dans
trois heures et la longue silhouette de
francis heaulme s'engouffre dans le
palais de justice de lyon deux heures
d'audition qui n'auront rien d'une
confession je suis un tueur en série
médiatisé dit francis heaulme
et à chaque fois qu'il ya un meurtre
c'est heaulme je commence à en avoir
assez
heaulme reconnaît bien avoir vu les
enfants vivant qui lui jetaient des
pierres
il reconnaît aussi avoir été ramassés
par les pêcheurs le visage ensanglanté
le jour du crime
j'étais tombé dit il pour le reste j'ai
tout inventé j'ai dit n'importe quoi
vous aviez tout de même raconté
s'interroge la présidente être monté sur
le talus avoir vu les enfants morts puis
avoir vu l'auteur du crime maintenant
vous dites encore autre chose pour le
savez bien d olmes je change à chaque
fois de version il me paraît évident que
aulnette impliquées dans cette affaire
n'étaient pas punis pour l'avocat de
l'île ce qu'ils disent et 300 pas de
supplément d'information le support
d'information encore une fois dit quasi
signature de haut niveau aujourd'hui on
a hole neuvième version mais la seule
constance que je
remarque c'est qu'il a toujours indiqué
qu'il n'était pas l'auteur de ce double
crime
les gendarmes avaient prévenu la cour
vous ne tirez rien de francis heaulme
car vous êtes en position de demandeur
vous n'avez plus aucun nouvel élément à
lui opposer francis ans il m'a
effectivement rien dit sauf rappelé
qu'elle était son genre mon style à moi
d'y heaulme celle opinel et j'ai trente
la même aussi puis il parle de patrick
dils
je pense souvent à lui et je pense qu'il
est innocent